dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly Jean IFA here what
are data sets a data set is typically a
big bunch of data for instance a
database of written letters digits
images of human faces stock market data
that scientists can use to test their
algorithms on if two research groups
wish to find out whose algorithm
performs better at recognizing traffic
signs they run their techniques on one
of these data sets and test their
methods on equal footings for instance
the canva data set stands for Cambridge
driving labelled video database and it
offers several hundreds of images
depicting a variety of driving scenarios
it is meant to be used to test
classification techniques the input is
an image and the question is for each of
the pixels which one of them belongs to
what class classes include roads
vegetation vehicles pedestrians
buildings trees and more these regions
are labeled with all the different
colors that you see on these images to
have the usable data set we have to
label tens of thousands of these images
and as you may imagine creating such
labelled images requires a ton of human
labour the first guy has to accurately
trace the edges of each of the
individual objects seen on every image
and there should be a second guy to
cross check and make sure everything is
in order
that's quite a chore and we haven't even
talked about all the other problems that
arise from processing footage created
with handheld cameras so this takes
quite a bit of time and effort with
stabilization and calibration as well so
how do we create huge and accurate
datasets without investing a remarkable
amount of human labor well here out this
incredible idea what if we could record
a video of us wandering about in an open
world computer game and annotate those
images and this way we can enjoy several
advantages one since we have recorded
continuous videos after annotating the
very first image we will have
information from the next frames
therefore if we do it well we can
propagate the labeling from one image to
the next one that's a huge time-saver to
UM
ah game one can stage and record
animations of important but rare
situations that would otherwise be
extremely difficult to film adding rain
or day and night cycles to a set of
images is also trivial because we simply
can query the game engine to do this for
us three not only that but the algorithm
also has some knowledge about the
rendering process itself this means that
it looks at how the game communicates
with the software drivers and the video
card tracks when the geometry and
textures for a given type of car are
being loaded or discarded and uses this
information to further help the label
propagation process and number four we
don't have any of the problems that stem
from using hand-held cameras noise
blurriness problems with the lens and so
on are all non issues using this
previous can be data set the annotation
of one image takes about 60 minutes
while with this data set seven seconds
thus the authors have published almost
25,000 high quality images in their
annotations to aid computer vision and
machine learning research in the future
that's a lot of images but of course the
ultimate question arises how do we know
if these are really high quality
training samples they were only taken
from a computer game after all while the
results show that using this data set we
can achieve an equivalent quality of
learning compared to the canva data set
by using 1/3 as many images excellent
piece of work absolutely loving the idea
of using video game footage as a
surrogate for real-world data fantastic
and in the meantime while we are
discussing computer graphics here's a
nice computer graphics challenge grant
from experiment basically if you start a
new research project through their
crowdfunded system you may win
additional funding that comes straight
from them free money if you are
interested in doing any kind of research
in this area or if you are a longtime
practitioner make sure to have a look
the link is available in the video
description box thanks for watching and
for your generous support and I'll see
you next time